all right let's jump into this first
story from the hill Ukraine Capital
preparing evacuation centers for
possible Nuclear Strike they're also
handing out potassium iodide Poland's
been doing the same thing and the other
big news here is that Poland suggests
hosting U.S nuclear weapons amid growing
fears of Putin's threats so look all of
this
you know when I see Ukraine and they're
they're giving up potassium iodide these
are the tablets you take to try and
protect your thyroid when there's radio
Radioactive particles everywhere and
they're prepping evacuation centers I
don't trust Ukraine look I don't like
that Russia invaded them I don't like
that Russia is annexing these regions I
don't like any of that stuff I don't
like what they do with Crimea but I
think Ukraine is desperate so they're
going to say whatever they need to say
to make it seem like the end is nigh and
we need to keep giving them money and
they just announced what another like
600 million dollars 625 or some
ridiculous number so when Ukraine's like
oh you prepare for a nuclear strike are
they doing that to freak us out to get
the headline or are they actually
concerned it's going to happen that
being said when Poland suggests hosting
U.S nuclear weapons which is basically
spitting in the face of Putin who said
do not move nukes into Eastern Europe
maybe it's not so much that they're
watching in Ukraine they're watching
Putin do something although that train
carrying like the nuclear mod Group
whatever was called they are saying that
but maybe the reason Ukraine is prepping
for a nuclear strike is because they
know what NATO is doing and they know
what NATO is doing will result in a
response from Vladimir Putin yeah I mean
let's be honest here if you're not
worried you're not paying attention to
what's going on here there's been severe
escalations on both sides this is headed
down down a trajectory of just further
uh dangerous Pathways that of course
don't have any diplomacies don't have
any dip to taunt don't have any
compromises the only reason why the
world wasn't blown up during the Cold
War is because people negotiated people
came to the negotiation table and said
okay let's figure this out let's make
sure we compromise on a deal that
benefits both of us so we could both get
away from killing each other and and
extinguishing and destroying the entire
world we're not having any of that the
president of Ukraine literally just
signed into law a decree that prevents
him from even negotiating with Vladimir
Putin and and having a peace deal with
him that that to me is absolutely absurd
and it's it is crazy yeah they frame
Kennedy as having just strong strong man
who was the Russian Premier at the time
it was Khrushchev to take take the nukes
out of Cuba and Khrushchev did it but
that's not what happened Kennedy used
diplomacy and he worked with khrush Jeff
and said we'll take our nukes out of
turkey if you take your nukes out of
Cuba it was a diplomatic action and
without diplomacy we're not going to see
the nukes we're not going to see the
escalation this is Will Chamberlain
brought this up well you're specifically
talking about the Cuban Missile Crisis
where not many people know this and
people didn't know this when it was
happening but as you mentioned JFK
compromised with Khrushchev and JFK
agreed to get rid of the missiles that
were located in Italy and in turkey that
Russia thought was going to be used
against them and therefore the Russians
were then only willing to compromise and
get rid of their missiles from Cuba
which of course threatened the United
States so that was a compromise hold on
how could JFK have done that surely the
information on where those nukes were
were classified and he wouldn't have the
authority to declassify any of
information like that right some some
greater Authority than the president I
mean that right am I wrong because it
turns out the president can declassify
1960s were different than 2022 well the
whole thing with Trump and the and the
classified documents just shows maybe
the country has been subjugated if the
president is now being attacked because
he had classified documents when
previously we had a President Who
revealed the location of our nuclear
weapons directly to our principal
adversary and that was a good thing
now Trump can't even have documents that
were empty folders apparently it just
goes to show that the presidency is
subjugated by something yeah what you
were saying earlier Jason you think
there's some sort of authoritarian
aspect here I'm looking I just got a
tweet from disclose.tv that the U.S is
to buy quote nuclear emergency drugs for
290 million dollars from a Florida
pharmaceutical company uh what is this
called Amgen is the name of the company
it's called n plate is the health and
human services drug 125 micrograms is
around twelve hundred dollars so don't
discount the pharmaceutical companies
attempt to profit off of a nuclear scare
oh man look potassium iodide is just
like it's cheap it's just it's nothing
it's potassium it's iodine you can get
iodine from your table salt you get that
unit I I what is it like iodine salt or
whatever the little Morton girl with the
umbrella or whatever that works too the
point of these pills is that it
Associates your thyroid it gives you all
the all the iodine you need so you don't
absorb the particles but I'm saying
I would not be surprised if these
companies come up with some way to make
something slightly different you know
what they add they'll add a little
aspirin to it and be like it'll protect
you from radiation and cure a headache
and it costs a thousand dollars that's
exactly what they're doing this is from
healthandhumanservices.gov HHS purchases
drug for use in radiological and nuclear
emergencies and they're going right to a
private pharmaceutical does it say what
the what the drug is uh yeah I think I
just mentioned it as an end plate
n-p-l-a-t-e I'd have to I'd have to look
into what that does sure it's a
subcutaneous uh subcutaneous powder for
injection according to Disclose TV then
they link us over to Health and Human
Services where they get the information
well I don't know man but do you guys
even think it's going to get to that
point I I kind of feel like everything
we've seen so far is is indicative of
escalation let me just say this the
rhetoric is very dangerous right so we
could go back a few months ago where you
had the head of the Russian space
division saying they could nuke all NATO
Nations within 30 minutes not great I'm
not very happy about that that's
something that was put out there you
have David Petraeus this week on CNN
discussing if the Russians were to use a
nuclear strike that we would basically
be able to use our military to take out
their entire Seaboard it's like not even
the Black Sea Fleet exactly
um how horrible that would be so the
language that's being used the things
that are being portrayed to the public
you talked about the iodine thing well
how about that New York City emergency
uh PSA where they're just talking about
a random nuclear weapon going off in the
city and what should we don't know why
we don't know how it's not important
we've never talked like this at least
not since the 80s you you were saying
the US did buy these these drugs yeah
they're ordering it right now as part of
the long-standing effort uh was this
so I I just you just check check this
out it's uh if you want to look it up
it's aspr aspr but if you look up what's
the website or what's the what's the
title I can go HHS purchases drug for
use in radiological and nuclear
emergencies
what do we got is that from Bloomberg no
it's from hhs.gov whoa
yo HHS buying 290 million dollars worth
of Amgen drug and plate for radiation
sickness in nuclear emergency whether
that's tax money being spent well
obviously well yeah yeah
it's called theft Ian so look here's
what I want to say sometimes they tell
you exactly what they're doing and
what's coming I mean if they're doing
this they're not keeping it a secret
from us that they think we're going to
nuclear war no it's dangerous and it's
it's not just Petraeus it seems like
everybody who supposedly is an
authoritative Source on this in our
military and on the media is saying that
tactical Nuclear strikes might be okay
this is insane you know you know what
really really pisses me off right now is
that this this company that's on this
drug didn't call it rat away
yeah really yeah they're missing the
market maybe they would have gotten sued
by by Bethesda shut up a Fallout this is
saying that let's call it right away the
biomedical Advanced research and
development Authority in 2004 uh got
some new Authority called project
bioshield act and can now I don't know
spend indiscriminately I don't know what
it can do with this project bioshield
act signed in 2004 sounds like a bush
thing probably afraid of you know there
was all this weapons of mass destruction
fear so they're like we gotta sign new
authoritarian laws to give us over
arcing uh authority to do whatever we
want so this is a treatment for acute
radiation sickness due to a radiological
or nuclear emergency and it is approved
for immune
thrombocytopenia a blood disorder
characterized by a low platelet count by
low platelet counts plural so um
maybe they're just like here's an
opportunity to give money to the
pharmaceutical companies or maybe
they're like
there's going to be a nuclear war
Putin's going to do it
here's the thing let's say a nuclear
bomb goes off anywhere in the world we
live in such a post-truth world that how
do you attribute that to anybody because
you know who the media is going to oh
dude look at nordstream exactly not only
that but the United States also on
record Lost nuclear weapons that they
can't account for and guess what the
Russians lost a lot more of them as well
especially when the Soviet Union
collapsed literally people walked into
military facilities and was like yeah
I'll give you a thousand rubles for that
and they're like yeah here here's your
nuclear weapon so there's a lot of
nuclear weapons that are out there
um that that we can't account for that
we don't know where they are they could
be in private hands they could be in
very Sinister hands they could be in
third parties that could profit off of
escalating this conflict and as we
talked about before maybe it's not even
the United States responsible for this
gas explosion maybe it's a private
industrial complex company organization
party or even third party like China
that's sitting back and saying well
maybe we could watch these two countries
fight each other and then grow in the
absence of of them obliterating each
each other what if there was like a
former special agent from like the UK
was like MI6 is that what it's called
MI6 yeah and then and what he did was he
got a bunch of other special agents to
come work for him and was like a rogue
Nation
well we got to understand we're living
in a place where multinational
corporations have a lot more power and
influence than governments we we have to
understand Biden right here is not
making not making any decisions he's not
calling the shots here he is someone
that is not of sound mind he can't make
coherent sentences there's no way he
could be handling the most stressful job
as described by many presidents of the
United States to be in that Oval Office
there's no way he is working non-stop
there's no way he's cutting deals
negotiating behind the closed doors
there's someone else calling the shots
here who is that person well I think
it's the people benefiting uh off of a
lot of his failed policies that destroy
the American lower and middle class and
of course prop up the billionaires the
bankers and of course the private
interest that I think are truly calling
the shots here who are uh you know
Psychopathic who will do anything to get
money to get power to get influence and
I think a lot of them are even satanic
but that's the whole different
perspective I don't even want to go down
there the the issue is
don't think about it in terms of the
NATO versus Russia think about it in
terms of something you believe is is
right and something you see someone
doing that you believe is wrong and then
think about your willingness to allow
them to keep doing it to to prevent a
fight this is this is the think about a
a a a a child drag show you know most
people probably do not want to see those
things
but when we have people going out and
protesting fights happen so this is the
problem we don't want the fighting but I
want you know people will you'll
understand the perspective of what what
NATO and what Russia are both feeling
they're both saying we will not stop
they're both saying if you want to avoid
war you back down and they're both
saying it exactly to each other because
they both think they're right I don't
think
for the most part A lot of these NATO
countries I think a lot of the people in
these countries think they're
legitimately correct and right I think
they're evil a lot of them I think their
attitude is elitist and the people are
stupid and we're better than them but
we're doing the right thing and they
should be grateful and I think Putin's
probably the exact same way but just not
aligned with them and so they're adamant
that they are deserving of their their
Quest towards their ideology and no one
is going to back down there's no
scenario I see Vladimir Putin being like
well NATO's expanding on my border
whatever Russia can Russia can just roll
over no way dude's gonna be like I want
to bring back the Soviet Union it was a
travesty that I mean he literally said
this and it's a travesty that that
collapse and our leaders let us down
this is not a guy who's going to be like
it's a good thing that Western forces
are taking over our country he thinks
it's a horrible thing Constantine
kissing translated his speech which
everyone should check out on Twitter
it's a long thread and Putin was
essentially intimating that the liberal
economic order has gone too far as
destroying Earth it's creating you know
it's satanic I think he even said at one
point and he will it's going it's
falling and he won't it's he's going to
make sure that it falls right he said
the Satanism thing in line with the
gender Idol ideology that's going to be
pushed and I actually watched uh
leninoff at the un uh in the previous
week and it was hard for me to just no
roosophile right I agree with you Tim
that Putin's not a great guy he's got
his mindset he has Authority
authoritarianism but when you have
leninoff sitting there talking about the
war on terror what we did in Afghanistan
Iraq Libya Somalia and Beyond it's hard
to argue with the guy what Freedom did
we bring you know are these
nation-states better off after our
intervention or are they worse off well
I think by any measure of the
imagination most of these plea most
these places have become even more
failed States they have slavery in Libya
for God's sakes I mean it's 2022 and
would that have happened without U.S
military intervention I doubt it you
know so so it's tough because their
rhetoric sounds pretty good right now
but then you have people biting on that
line that somehow you know Putin's the
good guy and he's fighting these people
I think that they're all fighting for
their vision of what globalism is going
to become in The Next Century and all
any regular person wants is to go into
their yard throw some feed to their
chickens collect some eggs Bring
breakfast to their family and then mind
their own business that's but
unfortunately there are ideologues and
there are zealots who are hell-bent on
controlling your life and some of them
amass tons of power and they want to
blow up kids take over your country and
take away your chickens and they amass
nuclear weapons which endanger the
entire world and then as Burma's pointed
out something that I've been saying from
the very beginning of this conflict
everyone's looking out for themselves uh
Putin is looking out for Putin he's
looking out also for his country his
interests the United States is looking
out for their interests and there's no
denying it especially with the moves
that have been made here but when do we
make a stop when do we like try to pause
this Insanity that has led us to this
situation where young men and and
innocent human beings are dying for the
political Ambitions of politicians that
to me is absurd thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there